[Music]
once
your mind was a place that only you
could go
but now anyone can drop in
and hear your thoughts mind to mind
communication
has finally arrived i'm gonna read your
thoughts
how would it change team sports
could you share images and feelings and
would everyone know your most private
thoughts
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if telepathy were real
telepathy is real no
not that type of telepathy i'm talking
about
scientifically created telepathy that
uses
electroencephalography or eeg
brain to brain communication first
happened
in 2014 during an experiment
conducted by star lab axillum robotics
and harvard medical school but
participants were
only able to send and receive simple
messages
and they had to use binary codes to
spell out each word
it was slow it could take
up to 70 minutes to send and receive
a four-letter message it was more like
morse code than
real telepathy but in the future
could there be fully functional
telepathy equipment
we have a long way to go before we can
share our thoughts
seamlessly with someone else but it's
not impossible
the 2014 study had to use binary codes
to send messages
because scientists don't know how the
brain
codes electrical signals but
if we can decode our brain's language
we would unlock our full telepathic
potential
we'd also need to create wearable tech
this is definitely not fashionable
instead
you'd have smaller eeg readers that look
slicker and
cooler eventually you could have the
option
of having the eeg reader permanently
installed
under your skin but that could leave you
vulnerable to hacking
i'll have more on that later the eeg
reader would allow you to send thoughts
as an electrical code
but you'd also need something to receive
code from other people
this is where magnets come in a magnetic
receiver would take
electrical signals translate them and
then
send currents through your brain tissue
and
we're not just talking about words here
but images and
feelings too in the 2014 study
scientists used a magnetic receiver to
activate
a part of the visual cortex which
triggered light flashes called
phosphines if scientists unlock
how the brain works different parts of
your brain could be triggered for
different types of communication but
this is where we get into some sticky
areas because
what if you don't want someone reading
your thoughts
to protect people from invasive mind
readers
the telepathy technology would need
strong protection
memories dreams fears
your passwords there are some things
you don't want other people to know if
you were to have
a removable eeg reader you could
put it on only when you want to use it
but
an implanted eeg reader would need some
sort of
off button otherwise you'd be vulnerable
to
mind-reading hackers accessing all of
your thoughts
and you'd also have to practice focusing
your mind
once that communication channel is open
anything could be sent through it
even those snippets of daydreams that
you don't want anyone else to
hear or see with widespread telepathy
our world would change drastically
you'd see team sports where the players
are linked up together moving in
synchronized motion
and complex gameplays creators and
innovators would be able to share their
ideas easier
and instead of trying to put thoughts
that are hard to communicate
into words you could simply share your
thoughts with others
in the meantime i use trends.co to learn
and collaborate with entrepreneurs
founders and the movers and shakers of
the world
might not be telepathy but i get to dive
deep into the minds of leaders of
every industry i can also share my ideas
get feedback and grow a community that
helps me get ahead of the newest craze
and with articles like the future of
media and pop culture
i can see how other media brands and
creators are growing their audiences
i love hearing from all sorts of
innovators in trends biweekly newsletter
highlighting stories from around the
community trends.co
is not just the ultimate knowledge hub
from the hustle
it's also a place where like-minded
people can build and
create together and hey
someday you might be able to link up
telepathically and get even greater
insight into the brightest business
minds but
for now you'll have to be content with
using a good old phone
tablet or computer to access inspiring
insights
oh and right now you can get your first
seven days for just one dollar
go to trends.co slash what if
for your seven day one dollar trial
and when you can access other people's
thoughts
and they're accessing yours you'd need a
way to
disconnect your brain would be
pretty cluttered if people could just
send you thoughts
all day and all night long and sometimes
you might not want to know what another
person is thinking
privacy would become more rare and new
mental health issues
could arise from extended use of
telepathy
if scientists could truly unlock the
mysteries of the brain
then the possibilities are endless
virtual reality simulations could be
sent right into your mind
you could record your dreams and maybe
you could even upload fake memories
[Music]
but that's a story for another
what if
you